time slows down on hot ones oh yeah it
seems like we've been here for weeks
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings today
I'm joined by Jack Black and Kyle Gass
together they're tenacious d the
self-described greatest band on earth
you can pick up their fourth studio
album post-apocalyptic set to drop on
November 2nd and to hold you over
they've release an animated web series
by the same name it's on YouTube check
it out after hot ones maybe Jack Kyle
welcome to the show
thanks good to be here how are you guys
with spicy food you cranked it up a
little bit I lack of the spice I crank
it now I feel like I'm overconfident
though I like the spice spice I'm going
to crank yeah well you know what we have
our Thai iced teas on deck so if that
was mine I know and all the first time
ever Jack you know why yeah yeah it'd
mean he always here like drink the milk
the milk is the best thing to do for his
bus and then other people say it nut
milk doesn't work nothing works and then
just today a dude was like you're going
on hot ones the secret is what sugary
water it deactivates this he was coming
at me with some science but then someone
else was like you know you need the fats
of the creams so I came up with this
Thai iced tea it's like a sugary water
with some creme de la creme well let's
put it to the test guys you ready No
[Music]
[Music]
now this is the easiest one this
probably gonna be not spicy at all just
plain old delicious huh so what I want
to do here is dig into some of the
behind the scenes mythology of tenacious
d kyle is it true that you couldn't
stand Jack when you first met him in the
late 80s that's not true that's so
that's enough
well you are really friendly I was
threatened by Jack and then his talent
he was younger than me but he seemed
already something special and I was a
little just yeah don't fret
that's how all great friendships begin
can't beat them I have to join them
alright I'll let you be my friend
exactly how it is
can you guys offer some highlights and
lowlights from the writer challenge a
tradition whereby you guys will eat
everything on your tour rider regardless
of quantity well that's
oh my god that's that's oh that's a
great thing that you found out about I
know that now I know about the rider
talents actually just a comedic idea
that I had yeah there was like what do
we got we got like pita bread we got
some hummus we got hummus we got a
charge a dark chocolate but it's overall
when you look at it the spread it's too
much food you're never gonna eat it off
it's stupid rock star stuff and then
you're usually a catering and then it
just goes to waste
it's really bad is there any truth to
the internet urban legend that you guys
started an earthquake in New Zealand
opening for the Foo Fighters now that is
true that is true that is actually
scientifically proven because they got a
good sensitive Richter scale system
there in New Zealand and when we were
doing tribute the whole crowd was was
bouncing so hard they said that it
registered on the Richter scale there
and they were afraid we were gonna cause
an earthquake that would sink the whole
islands so we had to like take it down a
notch
yeo-hwa yeo-hwa well here guajillo my
heel will get that correct pronunciation
oh you're so close white Baudelaire
chefs like how you throw the bones away
I like the chicken sanitation for
nutritious and also tell me baby they're
quite bootylicious that needs some work
so we've touched on the tour I dare
challenge but now that you guys are in
this seat I want to discuss some of the
other gourmet exploits of tenacious d
can you explain the Dorito burrito to
the people out there hmm
I believe that I've developed this
technique of burrito eating where you
take the burrito bite off just a tip
drain it
let the chunks fall on top of a bed of
chips to create nachos there and then
some dry chips stuff them in the hole
and fill this you know delicious burrito
satchel with with crunchy chips I love
it I just love a good crunch in a
burrito I'm gonna have my first look
just cause I like no early in the game
Kyle so that's not because you're
hurting oh I just like no
okay let's do this oh yeah hmm
raising the temperature on this game i
huh Wow yeah I'm still doing pretty good
yeah like my glasses are starting to
steam up a little bit a little bit I can
see that you guys have had this multi
decade-long collaboration but also your
fair share of solo projects so what I
want to do is talk about some of the
times you guys have gone off into your
own pastures to see how they were viewed
through the eyes of your partner in
crime
how what do you think is the pinnacle of
Jax acting career uh well I love Bernie
a lot that was really a great
performance thank you
Jack what's your favorite episode of
guitar ins the internet guitar tutorial
series hosted by Kyle Gass I think the
one that you did with Josh Homme II yeah
was special because of all the living
rock guitarists I think he's the best
this is so rad Bruce Eilish and it was a
cool it's like how did you get cha-cha
me I know that we run in the same
circles but the fact that you got him on
your show was I was impressed
I was scared down there my show yeah
really you will okay Kyle what do you
think is Jack's best celebrity
impression I've seen him do a great one
of the rock when he was doing press for
Jumanji I did like that rock was funny I
just got a hot sauce oh did you we have
only just begun oh no it's gonna be
trouble I told you trouble like someone
spiked my wings oh [ __ ]
here we go
hmm oh yeah oh I do one really good
impression Paul Lynde walls for it's
like 1960s hit me he was on like a
bewitched and he was like ah yeah and
that's really all I can do I just say
that one that was I'm starting to feel
it
I'm gonna take your number take my first
set no shame in that hope this works
so one of the funniest things has seen
nerdy music writers describe your live
shows would feature everything from
sasquatch cameos and even an oversized
ejaculating Phoenix looking back what do
you think was your most disastrous live
performance oh it's pretty easy Miller
Genuine Draft yeah that was possessed
that was a Hasker promotion MGD blind
date for this beer and they fly
everybody to Vegas to see a secret band
yeah it's a radio contest like if you
heard on the radio and you're called in
you're the 13th caller you get to fly
and they fly out they don't tell you the
bandits so everyone's just like oh man I
bet it's like it's probably gonna be you
toots I'm gonna be less than Lynne it's
probably gonna be and so and then the
curtain opens and it's all these drunk
people from all over the country have
been flown to Vegas and then it's
Tenacious D and that's just immediately
nobody knows around Kings on - jeez 110
Jeff is flying at us and spit and ice
cubes and like we're like natured and
I'm looking around and say anyone that's
enjoying this and I look in the back and
there's a dude going and I'm like that
dude loves doesn't it like
it's like a horrible homophobic dude but
I looked in the wigs because we had
spider-man in the wings our friend
Junior and he's supposed to come out and
we do this whole comedy bit with
spider-man and he was in the wings and
he was like no no Spidey - no no that's
but I felt like after that I felt like
we got stronger we were stronger because
of it because there was something really
funny about being booed that hard - yeah
in a weird way it might have been our
best show if someone can get a videotape
of that I'd appreciate it I'm loving all
these chickens because there's simply
quite nutritious and also tell me a baby
quite well delicious it's getting better
the jam is getting more solid it's
coming together
[Music]
[Music]
good you good you good - good - good all
right guys won't every current segment
on our show cult explain that Graham
where you do a deep dive and I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the picture then
you tell me the bigger story does that
sound good
mmm all right laptop please how you guys
doing so far it seems like very good I'm
feeling good
this is I feel like we're starting to
really get to it oh yeah what goes in to
putting together this type of
pyrotechnic display it was for an awards
show on Spike TV the video game awards
and you know who wrote this opening
sketch which was a it was kind of an
amazing musical number sketch thing JT
RZA JT r is gnar was one of the writers
but also Dan Harmon who co-creator of
Rick and Morty funniest show and that
was a funny ass idea that we would have
explosive spark shooting [ __ ] and there
was a fireman on hand yes
rather app ready to put out our flaming
[ __ ] if need be ah memories
thus concludes explain oh man that's a
good thing much speaking of fiery [ __ ]
time for another send it all down a
husband yeah how's that true huh
oh god has hurry taste hmm hmm yeah the
flavor the Middle East so during this
vh1 storytellers Kanye West broke down
the lyrics of Robocop and he said that
he had some Tenacious D in it that it
was his first real Jack black moment and
then Jack I've seen you sing and run
away on your Instagram feed
do you see tenacious deep influence and
Kanye West's music at all well he said
it didn't so look I loved it that Kanye
gave us a shout out I would definitely
definitely give me a little woody Kanye
gave us a shout out because I love Konya
I think he's got great great jams really
good jams but he also gave a Donald
Trump a shout out and that guy's a
douche so it's weird it's like wait yeah
does that take away from the compliment
he gave to us a little bit no he's very
talented
there's no question about it yeah
separate the art from the artist I love
it even his most recent jams
the one that he did with a little palm
funny it was actually funny you know
what I think I think about about Kanye
that's similar to us though is we're all
about being the best band in the world
and he's he's very much in that same
vein of being the greatest you know he
likes to toot his own horn but I think
we're a little more tongue-in-cheek than
his I think he really he's high on his
own supply
all [ __ ] where we adding that firewater
but they're not [ __ ] around when they
put the skull at the stall God wants his
trouble [ __ ] this is where it's getting
serious I I'm not one of these nibblers
you know get in there okay all right no
there's trouble color okay looks and
crannies oh boy okay all right let's see
what you did here yep lightweight
MacGyver Hillman throw oh my god oh my
god Oh gauge there's no shame in letting
me be the victor there's no shame of all
the tongues of flame Hey we turned the
corner there mm-hmm
there was a cosmic leap between Wang
number six number seven
oh okay I'd like to say though I don't
know if you noticed I did do a hot wing
challenge before but it was on David
Letterman that's him I remember when I
did it know and I felt like it was like
David Letterman was like mad at me or
something
because he had me I was like hey would
you mind doing like a little hot wing
challenge oh yeah
oh my god that's only number seven did I
don't know if I'm gonna make it I don't
know is this the challenge you give to
everybody or it is harder than most did
you did you use that I should have eaten
every nook and cranny you know it is
funny cuz you're like I'm not one of
these nibblers and then now do it I
might switch over to nibble if it gets
hotter than that I'm [ __ ]
of course it does you can sweetie that
goes down now we have a soupy your milk
I want to see if it works better than my
Thai iced tea over here
mmm-maybe mm-hmm yeah the sugar I think
so a feature a lot of rappers on this
show but not nearly enough rockers on
this wing I want to dig into your
collective love of the genre to make
some recommendations and settle some
age-old debates if you're trying to
convince somebody that 80s metal isn't
just loud noises what album would you
recommend I need like some milky
chapstick it feels fine as long as the
milk is in there
and as long as my tongue is soaking in
milk but as soon as I stop smoking no
there then that loses the glaze well 80s
metal I go straight for Ozzy because you
got Randy Rhoads on guitar and Randy
Rhoads he was a great mixture of like
blues and the classical music so solos
were like little mathematical
masterpieces I can't think straight
because of the spice yeah I know this is
becoming miserable it's almost like yes
what a mushroom either I'm just looking
at that next wing and thinking about the
dread I'm feeling about the you know
it's not just look at what it's called
math who is called you're the you're
checking the sauces that's jib bomb Oh
oh I could say it since that was trouble
Oh God and Shawn's over there
hypnotized deep
all right the bomb
it's gonna look like you guys have
switched drinks there's no there's
nowhere to run
oh all right well you guys have known
each other since the 80s toured the
globe for albums and even a feature film
but how well do you really know each
other it's time to dust off the bucket
Oh BFF questions and this is how it
works you guys reach into the bucket and
pull a question jack when you reach in
the bucket you'll ask the question to
Kyle Kyle when you reach in the bucket
you'll ask the question to jack
[Music]
when's the last time you were actually
pissed off of me I was mad at the
beginning when you saw my Thai iced tea
you really mad
that's like like genuine makes the math
I was genuinely mad oh my god dude I'm
sorry I was just scared about this
moment here and I would never write
anecdote mmm I was right
there's nothing works dude nothing works
[Music]
it's the delay okay - the delay
it's just time time is the only thing
that makes it go away someday this will
be over let's get the thing about time
slows down on hot ones oh yeah it seems
like we've been here for weeks
kind of like a hospital moving did this
is brutal have with is it is this the
most anyone's complaint can't believe
there's a hotter one than that
well here's the good news you get to win
I'm out I don't know dude yeah powers
wins it might be a tie they're gonna I
don't know if I am I think I might be
done do you feel like we're about yeah I
feel like I'm about to die not really
[ __ ] hate you oh my god you're doing it
all
thank you [ __ ] Exorcist look out kids
I think I sent one down your crotch
[Music]
I want to send it down the hatch pass
button so I'd be remiss to have you guys
in the chair not talk about tenacious d
lyrics which have befuddled and amused
fans and even bubbled up in pop culture
sports center anchor Scott Van Pelt used
to sneak tenacious deve lyrics in to
highlight reads with how about the power
of flight that do anything for you and
that's levitation Holmes do you guys get
a kick out of that
yeah as rad huge kick well I mean that's
where we got the the the name of our
band and the kinesin was like sports
journalists and sports commentator who
was it
Marv Albert Thank You Marv Albert I
think he was the first one who said
tenacious d or that I remember to hear
it come back to us through tenacious d
lyrics through through the sports media
was a pretty what's better than that
though and it's really uh it's kind of
like you did it was being an answer on
Jeopardy yeah is it good twice twice
shall we is the time it's that time boy
wait a second what are you why are you
shaking
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
oh man you don't care oh look at that
evil if not good job
oh there's a chunk those enough now that
you've done it I feel like you're like I
do have to all right careful well well
no you can't do it I can get rid of the
excess
all right guys cheers cheers Cheers
what's going down that's wrong
[Music]
all right tenacious d here we are at the
end of the line and we've had some great
live music performances on hot ones from
t-pain sultry singing and to John
Mayer's impromptu ditty but now it's
time to give the wings of death the rock
tribute that they deserve and we're
digging deep into our nut sacks for the
rocket sauce on this one we have a
collection of instruments grab your axe
a tambourine an accordion ukuleles
flutes recorders it's all going down
let's close this one out with a little
impromptu ditty mmm about the hot ones
gauntlet for the people out there
[Music]
[Music]
oh look at you guys clearing out the
board you didn't think you could do it
but you're done deed you found it deep
in the nutsack on that rocket sauce and
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you guys this
camera this camera and this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life Oh check out our news show
our webseries post-apocalyptic only on
the youtubes on the tenacious d youtube
channel check out trainwreck check out
my new [ __ ] band what's what's a kind
of like tough is like the amount of
liquids that I pour down my gullet
that's where you got to be careful for
real yeah almost like where's the my god
yeah you have to watch out yeah he's
create a lot of this ya know it's a
bubbling cauldron in there now yeah yeah
1 million - 1 million 3 that's pretty
good form Phil then you get that cool
shirt you didn't hear how ones merch
it's available now I thought you only
wore Where's Waldo shirts I used to wear
Where's Waldo shirts one
[Music]